Enrique Acevedo is an anchor for
Univision he joins us down enrique you
seem like a reasonable person how did
you wind up with the group in the media
defending ms-13 do you ever think you'd
be there I don't think any human being
it's an animal talker but I'm not here
to defend criminals nor should anyone
else oh no an order if you're for law
and order I don't think the grading
anyone to less than human serves that
purpose you would expect the President
of the United States to speak to our
highest ideals and not just our worst
insuk so so let's let's just just to put
this in some context here a couple
recent headlines about ms-13 ms-13 gang
stay at stabbed man a hundred times
decapitated him and ripped out his heart
police say ms-13 beats X traffic girl
with a bat 28 times ms-13 members were
in satanic shrine kidnapped drugged and
raped 240 no Houston draw I could go on
when you hear those people described as
animals you get offended why what why
would people who do that need to be
defended by you what about what Trump
said sort of got you going I think we
can not pretend to look at this in a
larger context we cannot pretend that
this is not part of a larger trend that
started way before Donald Trump became
president a trend of criminalizing and
dehumanizing all immigrants not just the
bad numbers the question was about gang
members who are operating inside the
u.s. President Trump and how the border
animals no I it was I mean look I'm not
here to defend all of Trump's views but
in this very specific case he was asked
about ms-13 he's been talking about this
for more than a year then he said
they're animals now you may not like the
term maybe it's imprecise or whatever
but I find it so interesting that you
rush to the defense of ms-13 is there no
one else you can defend they're not
other worthy people being attacked you
need to defend the street gang that
we're succeeding and beheads people like
do you wake up in the morning and ask
yourself like how did I get here
I'm a decent person why am i defending
ms-13 I'm not sure what you mean when
you say that I defended ms-13 I actually
was defending them my started this
interview by saying I'm not here to
defend any criminals
human under saying that no no human
being is an animal that's what I'm
saying law and order insert there's no
cause of chaos and lawlessness okay
we're all animals okay just as a
biological question maybe that the term
is imprecise maybe you don't like it but
you're rushing to the defense and it's
not just you it's John Harwood at the
New York Times it's the entire media
establishment and the Democratic Party
is unable to admit that there are
immigrants who shouldn't be here they're
horrible they kill people especially the
poor and the vulnerable and ms-13 is and
I think we agree on that point there are
a lot of bad apples inside this
president Trump and Jeff Sessions should
work with the Hispanic community to try
to root those bad apples out of their
federal funding from sanctuary cities so
they won't report crimes and doesn't
have a monopoly on the concerns of all
Americans of all colors and backgrounds
ethnicities about crime it has nothing
to do with Hispanic or black or white
it's Americans don't want animals like
this in the country and again I just ask
you why did it bother you when he said
that I think it's rather me because you
know I think it you have to put things
in context and I'll do that for you okay
the contact context here it has to do
with a larger trend with President Trump
calling Mexican immigrants rapists and
then calling some white national is very
fine people the context here has to do
with President Trump pardoning Arpaio
and canceling that kind of context here
has to do with a constant conflating of
immigration and criminality when have
you heard someone in the Trump
administration say something positive
about immigrants first of all they have
whatever if they're are required by the
Constitution to compliment immigrants
sorry
second you may not agree with all of his
policies but in this again this specific
case he's criticizing people who are
evil and are killing once again the poor
and the defenseless and you've been
driven so crazy by Trump that you can't
even accept that as true if I attacked
Charles Manson as an
does that bother you of course not and
you know what I agree with president
Trump because he's not an immigrant
should be deported but guess what last
year arrests ice arrests were up by 30
percent and the larger percentage of
that increased had to do with non
criminal immigrants so if they want to
get rid of the bad numbers instead of
separating families they should focus on
that no criminal records wait why don't
we look people who are here legally
should be deported that's what the law
says if you don't like the law change it
in the Congress if you're here just
we've named dangerous criminals I know
there's criminals for three suppose
every time and energy on those people
and the bottom burdened by foreigners
about who we can deport in who we can
our law says if you're here illegally we
get to deport you period I'm sure a lot
of good people would be deported if we
did that I feel sad about it but that's
our law request asylum and we were also
criticizing that last week when the
accident came to the law and foreigners
have no right to weigh in on our Asylum
laws because they're on voters or
citizens we get to decide and but final
question why does it not bother you when
I call Charles Manson an animal but it
does bother you when Trump calls ms-13
animals it bothers me when any criminal
commits such horrific acts of
criminality and I see how people can be
deeply affected by them but I don't
think that degrading someone to less
than human serves a purpose of law and
order per second Trump seems to
understand very well what speaks to the
Trump base audience the concerns of his
rallies
so hurry of his you speak for all
Hispanics leader of Hispanics now
where'd you how did you get that job are
you elected to it no I'm not speaking
for Hispanics we should speak to his
fans very quickly let me ask you who do
you think the victims of ms-13 violence
are overwhelmingly are they Fox well you
know who jeez who are fleeing that
violence and trying to come into this
country but you're calling them people
who are trying to take advantage of our
legal system the vast majority of the
ms-13 and our Salvatrucha victims are
the people in Honduras and
that's to end in here coming here by the
way let me just say last thing I gotta
go
please convince the Democrats to run in
defense of ms-13 I think it's a
fantastic campaign plank I think your
mistake to the Fendi criminal what you
do anyway thank you great to see you
tonight
I appreciate thank you Thank You Tucker
well even when the media admitted the
President Trump was in fact talking
about M&S 13 they couldn't stop
themselves from defending ms-13 see
NBC's John Harwood weighed in on Twitter
as he often does quote however repugnant
their actions he said speaking the banal
DS for which he is famous
ms-13 gang members are human beings in
my humble opinion CNN's Anna Navarro
went farther of course he does things
like all immigrants animals the defense
is that he was following up by a
statement of a sheriff saying that this
is ms-13 he was just talking about ms-13
good enough no not good enough and it is
a very slippery slope when you start
dehumanizing people this way
it's what the Nazis did it's what slave
owners did it's not what Americans do
America's moral voice and a Navarro
speaking from CNN Larry O'Connor is
associated of the Washington Times and
he joins us tonight that's not what
Americans do yes Larry Susanna Navarro
at CNN you know that's what the Nazis
did I don't expect much from Anna
Navarro you know what I found most
telling about that clip Chris Cuomo
calling what Donald Trump said you know
he says his defense is he was talking
about ms-13 that his defense it's the
fact it's the truth he wasn't defending
himself that was actually the truth that
the media didn't report but for Chris
Cuomo to act like oh gosh how can this
be how can you talk about ms-13 you know
it's like saying that I can't discern
from the Gambino crime family and Chris
Cuomo or any other asian-american or
exactly it's it's outrageous and this is
my biggest problem as you said you
didn't even seeing Nancy Pelosi and
Chuck Schumer and all these other people
who are condemning the remarks based on
a lie and now 24 hours later you'd think
you'd see some retractions you'd see
think you'd see some Corrections and the
best they've got is well even ms-13
deserves to not be dehumanized you know
if you can't call ms-13 gang members
animals if you can't call them out on
their
pugna repulsive behavior you've
surrendered your ability to make any
moral judgments in our society the first
draft and I don't do too many media
segments because obviously they're just
dumb and there aren't armed in the
Democratic Party but the first draft of
their stories said that Trump had
attacked undocumented immigrant migrants
migrants or or many who cross the border
so that was a Democratic Party talking
point it was a flat-out absolute total
lie and it was CNN New York Times
Washington Post ABC News NBC News c-span
even c-span who pretends to be
completely down the middle I think
usually they are they did the same so
why aren't why shouldn't these be
reporters in-kind contributions the
Democratic National Committee it's a
great question or or maybe they should a
good Associated Press by the way the
only ones whoops that I've seen who
fully retracted it and deleted their
tweets but why aren't they called up on
any kind of ethics question but Jeff
bases his paper didn't I haven't seen
any retraction from them they've said
further context suggesting that it was
out of context but it wasn't out of
context that they took the president
they lied about what the probability
that a complete misrepresent
always great to see you great to st.
tell you thank you